[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS JACKSON: Hi, everybody.
How you doing?
What's up?
So thank you for allowing
me to come and play
with you guys today.
This is the most fascinating
building in the entire world.
I'm only going to
say, OK, Google, once.
We'll just get that
out of the way.
I'm really, really,
really, really
excited to be up here,
firstly because I don't really
have a show to do
tonight which makes
my life a whole lot easier,
which is a lot more than I can
say for these three
amazing performers
that we're going to
get to meet today.
And I'm just going to call them
up right now because we just
need to hear from them.
Ashley Park, from "Mean
Girls," Ari Stachel
from "The Band's Visit," and
Ariana DeBose from "The Donna
Summer Musical."
Hi, guys.
ASHLEY PARK: What's up
ARIANA DEBOSE: Hello.
CHRIS JACKSON: What's up?
This is your life right now.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Google.
CHRIS JACKSON: So
full disclaimer,
I just got to meet Ashley
just a little while ago.
I've done a little
show with Ari--
you guys might have heard of.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Two Aris.
CHRIS JACKSON: Right, and
Mr. Stachel here, well, we
go way back, but I'll let
him tell that story to you
as you are.
ASHLEY PARK: Oh, no.
What a mystery.
CHRIS JACKSON: All three
of these amazing actors
are nominated for Tonys in the
best featured actor and actress
category.
And so I guess,
firstly, I just want
to know, how's your life
changed in the last few weeks?
ASHLEY PARK: Where am I?
I don't know.
Well, we're still
doing 8 shows a week.
I think it's just, it's super,
super busy, it's super crazy,
it's super exciting.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah, I was going
to say, I'm a heck of a lot
busier than I was, but
it's really exciting,
for all the good reasons.
I did have that revelation
the other day of like,
no matter what I do from now
on, when they introduce us,
they're like Tony
nominee so-and-so.
That's really cool.
CHRIS JACKSON: First
line of your obituary.
ARI'EL STACHEL: I
was going to say,
like I haven't really made sense
of how my life has changed,
but I've been in
like the same room
eating steak with
Denzel Washington
like five times in
the last three weeks.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Not bad.
Not bad at all.
ARI'EL STACHEL: It
changed in that way.
ASHLEY PARK: It
really is a whirlwind.
And it's so crazy that
everyone's like, it's
been building up to this week.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah.
Five days.
ASHLEY PARK: I know.
CHRIS JACKSON: I'm going to
ask the other obvious question.
Where were you
when you found out?
What were you doing?
Who were you with?
ARIANA DEBOSE: I was sitting
on my couch with my cat.
ASHLEY PARK: You have cats?
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah,
I have two cats.
ASHLEY PARK: You too?
You are such a cat person.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah,
I'm a cat lady.
I'm 70.
ASHLEY PARK: That makes sense.
ARIANA DEBOSE: We're OK with it.
I was watching the
live stream, just
like cheering for everyone.
And then I got a text
from Laura Haywood, who
runs AOL Build, one
of the interviewers,
and she was like, I knew it.
And so I burst into
tears because I was like,
this is a sick joke.
And then, because
there's a delay, and then
I saw my face on my laptop
and I burst into tears again
because I couldn't believe it.
Yeah, so I cried.
ASHLEY PARK: Now you.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Now me?
We were performing
on the Today Show,
and they wanted to
coincide, I think,
our performance with
the announcements.
ASHLEY PARK: Oh, my god, you
were doing the Today Show
that morning?
ARI'EL STACHEL: It was awesome.
I was up at like
4:00 AM to show up.
And we had to promise to keep
our phones in the green room,
which was the
worst part about it
because we couldn't look at it.
So my poor publicist,
who is here in the back,
I was like looking at him
as I was performing on this,
on live television,
because I wanted to know.
And so we're freaking out,
and they were actually,
our categories, I
think, come later.
I think the leading
categories are early.
ASHLEY PARK: The last one.
CHRIS JACKSON: The last one.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah,
we were the last ones,
and so I think at 8:50
is when we performed.
But by that point,
they'd already
announced that our show had
received seven nominations.
And I was looking back
at him, and he was still
not giving me anything.
CHRIS JACKSON: Because
he's good at his job.
ARI'EL STACHEL: He's
good at his job.
But then we finished, and
I think at that point,
it was like 9:00,
and at that point
all the nominations came out and
our lead producer came to me,
and he was like, congrats, man.
I was like, yeah,
this is so awesome.
And he was like, no, you
got an individual one.
And I started crying, man.
I was just weeping.
ASHLEY PARK: You were
still at the Today Show?
ARI'EL STACHEL: I was
still at the Today Show.
ASHLEY PARK: I
want that footage.
Who has that footage?
CHRIS JACKSON:
Millions of people.
I was blubbering like--
ARI'EL STACHEL: No,
I was weeping, man,
and then my cast made a mentor,
like Tony Zilu, who also
got nominated, just
hugged me, and it
was like the first of many.
And then I cried more.
And then I went in--
ASHLEY PARK: Let's see if
we can make him cry today.
CHRIS JACKSON: I'm
on it, I'm on it.
ASHLEY PARK: Yeah.
It's so crazy because the Tonys
are the last of the awards.
And there's like a couple of
weeks of just so many things
being announced up until then.
And I think by that
point, I was like, you
know what, for this one, I call
up to my best girlfriends who--
they've known me for a while.
We've all traveled
together-- and I was like,
do you guys want to go
on a walk in Central Park
at this time, this morning?
And they were like, oh, we
know what this is about.
So we got coffee and juices
and we put our phones away,
and I was like, let me just see
if we can just forget about it
for a second.
And I will genuinely-- no,
listen, because I knew that
and also we were
going to rehearse
for the Today Show
that day, our show,
and I knew I was going
to see everybody.
And so I was like,
you know what?
I'll put my phone
away and like, I
don't want to jinx it either
way, so like if I pull it out
and there's a bunch of stuff,
then I'll know something
happened.
So I will honestly
say that I think we
were talking about face masks.
I hadn't my girlfriends
in like so long
because we're so busy, right?
And I genuinely was
pulling out my phone
to be like, oh, my gosh,
I just found this thing.
And then I open it, and
there's a bazillion things.
And I was like, oh, OK.
And they're like, what?
Can we look at our phones now?
But we were in Central
Park, and there's
no cell service in Central Park,
so then we couldn't figure out
what was going on.
CHRIS JACKSON: Go
to the great lawn.
There's like the biggest space.
That's all right.
We'll will talk about it later.
That's fine.
ASHLEY PARK: Yeah,
and then I just spent
the rest of the
morning like wandering,
and then that day, like after
the Today Show rehearsal,
we went to go look at our
big billboard in Times Square
for the first time as a cast.
It was really, really cool.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah, those
billboards move quickly,
don't they?
ASHLEY PARK: Ours
is the biggest.
ARIANA DEBOSE: I'll actually
agree with that statement.
ARI'EL STACHEL: I
perform on low for you
guys on Saturday Night Live.
I understand.
ASHLEY PARK: I know.
He's going to cry now.
CHRIS JACKSON: Now, Ms. DeBose.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yes, darling.
CHRIS JACKSON: You
have held roles
in "Hamilton" and
"A Bronx Tale,"
bringing on the musical
"Motown" and "Pippin."
You have been a dance machine
for a very, very long time,
and considered one of
the best dancers that
has stood on a Broadway stage
in the last 10 years, at least.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Thank you.
CHRIS JACKSON: How do
you find this transition
from your work,
that type of work,
to now helping lead a very
large, successful musical?
ARIANA DEBOSE: I wish I
could say it was seamless.
It's not exactly easy.
I think what is a comfort to
this transition is that I have
still been able to keep
my love for dance so pure,
and I can infuse it
into what I'm doing now.
No one told me I
didn't have to dance.
So we had this talk
once, and he looked at me
backstage at "Hamilton" and was
like, no matter what you do,
you always need to dance.
That's your gift.
So when I decided to
seek larger challenges,
that was part of the challenge.
How do I keep dance a part of
this job, in this line of work?
And I think it just
makes it harder,
in a beautiful way because you
have to double your stamina.
You take care of your
body differently.
It's not just your voice.
It's like there are three
different components
to what it is that I do,
in conjunction with leading
a company.
And I am very fortunate
to be able to have
a great partner in
LaChanze, and she really
can take the lead on that.
And therefore, my work
is part of how I lead
and I lead by example.
I might defer to her.
She's much more
eloquent than I am,
and she just has this
beautiful motherly energy.
So I don't have
to try to do that.
I can let her do that.
And we're a great
team in that way.
And then I'm just like
the favorite little sister
over here who happens
to say a bunch of words,
dance the little dance steps,
and move the plot along.
So it's been wonderful
getting my sea legs
and being someone now who is
a little more recognizable,
who does have to sit up here
and talk and make sense.
But it's fun.
ASHLEY PARK: As
someone who's seen you,
I mean, I'm realizing right
now that I saw you bring it on.
I saw you in "Hamilton."
I saw you in "Bronx Tale."
We've been friends
for a while, and I
think that's so beautiful.
It's so funny to hear you
talk about it so humbly,
in terms of like,
you've been trying
to make dance a part
of what you keep
doing because I don't think
there's a lot of people
who can do what you're doing.
And I think you do
it so beautifully,
and I love that you started
in ensemble because I think
you're really good with that.
ARIANA DEBOSE: You
know what that is?
ASHLEY PARK: I know.
I think that's why you
are able to be there
for your cast in that way too.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Thank you.
ASHLEY PARK: Sorry to
cut in, but I just, I'm
realizing right now
I really love you.
CHRIS JACKSON: That's the
discussion aspect of it.
We're good.
ARIANA DEBOSE: And
I think that's cool.
Like it does give me a
different perspective
because I did start
out in the ensemble,
and you relate to your company
differently in that way.
And it's been really nice.
There have been a few moments
where a few of my girls
needed a little
support, like just maybe
to get their shoes taken care
of, and I was able to be like,
hey guys, let's put my
dress on hold for a second.
And let's go out and
shop new shoes for them.
And that was real nice.
CHRIS JACKSON: So
they don't die.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah.
I was like, they're
dancing their face off,
playing women and men.
I'm like, you know what?
We should probably get them
some comfortable heels,
or let's refit this flat shoe.
I'll be fine.
So that's been cool.
CHRIS JACKSON: Fantastic.
All right, it says you
auditioned for your role
several times?
ARI'EL STACHEL: Seven.
CHRIS JACKSON: Seven.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Seven
times, over nine months.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Oh, that's
a long time to wait.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah.
It wasn't just waiting.
It was like crying in bed, but--
ASHLEY PARK: Again
with the crying.
CHRIS JACKSON: No,
but all jokes aside.
What was the process like?
ARI'EL STACHEL: The process,
listen, man, and I'm
going to go ahead and tell.
This is very significant
for me right now.
This is probably the
most exciting part
of this entire month
is learning that I
was going to talk to you.
I met Chris when I was
17, and I was trying
to choose college programs.
And one of the programs
that I got into was NYU,
and on that day, I
took a train ride.
I didn't even know how
to get on the train.
And I got there, and I
got to "In the Heights,"
the show that I had
admired so much.
CHRIS JACKSON: We both
had a lot more hair then.
ARI'EL STACHEL: We
had a lot more hair,
and I remember, I was
at the stage door,
and I went up to Chris,
and I was like, yo, like,
oh, you mean so much
to me, da da da da.
And he was gracious
enough to actually,
after signing his autograph,
he said, yo, come here man.
I was like, urh?
And he--
CHRIS JACKSON: It
doesn't dark, I promise.
ARI'EL STACHEL: No, and
he brought me backstage,
and this was the first time
I've ever been in New York
on a Broadway stage.
And he looked up, and
he was like, yo, man.
It's just a mezzanine.
Just learn how to
tell the story.
But I'm saying that in some
way to relate to the question
that you asked, which is
that at that time in my life,
I was concealing the fact that
I was a Middle Eastern person.
And so I think part of
learning how to tell the story
was to learn how
to accept myself.
And I literally
pretended that I was not
Middle Eastern for like
a third of my adult life
because I thought it would be
prohibitive for me as an actor.
And so when this show came
about and I saw this audition,
I was scared of it.
I was scared of what it would
mean to publicly be that
and what that would mean for me,
how that would limit my career
prospects.
And so I think that
nine-month span was really
a personal journey about
removing the distance that I
had between myself
and what it means
to be a Middle Eastern man.
And by the final audition, I
let the humanity come first,
and I realized it was
OK to be all of me
and be Middle Eastern
at the same time.
And so it was a really
sort of spiritual process,
and I'm grateful for
that because it also
taught me a lot about
resilience and forging--
ASHLEY PARK: I
got-- joke's on me.
I'm crying.
ARI'EL STACHEL:
Forging ahead, man.
Sorry.
But it's been transformative.
I mean, it was agony.
I mean, you want to do it and
you don't feel like you can,
but now, it's this wonderful
sort of hybrid for me of this--
I'm sitting here with amazing
Tony-nominated actors.
But the show is also
having a social impact,
and so I answered five
questions that you didn't ask.
CHRIS JACKSON: But also, I
think that the best art evokes--
it brings out something.
It requires something of you.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah,
yeah, I think so.
I think you need
skin in the game.
Like I don't think I
have-- these girls,
like I can't dance like that.
You know what I'm saying?
Like she's so funny.
Like if she is so
naturally-- like I
don't feel like I have that, and
so I think to sort of penetrate
this business, there
needs to be a lot
of your own skin in the game.
Like it needs to undeniably be
yours because there's literally
a hundred people who are really,
really good who want your job.
So something needs to
spark in that room.
ASHLEY PARK: I mean, I've
seen you in your show too.
I mean, I sound
like a super fan.
I've seen everybody
and everything.
No, but I feel like you
were 100% that character.
That character's 100% you.
There's no one else.
You own it.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Because
of the skin in the game.
You know what I'm saying?
ASHLEY PARK: God,
I love what you
said about feeling like
you have to hide being--
Google, thank you for having us.
This is like the best.
It's like really cathartic.
CHRIS JACKSON: Actor
therapy on a Tuesday.
This is what happens when
you get nominated for a Tony,
and you're doing
eight shows a week.
You are so raw.
Like everything is
just, I love you too!
You see people from other shows
whose performances you haven't
seen, but you're all suffering,
and you're all so happy,
and you're all so tired.
And you got nodes
on your chords.
And you haven't talked
to your mama in 15 days.
It just, it's all
of those things.
ASHLEY PARK: But
we're like in jeans,
and we were just saying, like
we were like, oh, my gosh.
This is like three ethnic
up and comers in a--
ARIANA DEBOSE: Rare.
ASHLEY PARK: Rare.
Rare to see this
type of diversity.
You know what I mean?
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah,
yeah, that's wonderful.
ASHLEY PARK: It's so cool.
CHRIS JACKSON: And I'm just
long enough in the tooth
to have been around when--
when I graduated
college, the only show
that I could have been
cast in was "Showboat"
because there were no
black people on Broadway.
There were no stories that
were inclusive in that regard.
And in the last 20 years,
thankfully, that has just--
ARIANA DEBOSE: That has changed.
ASHLEY PARK: And you've been
such a huge part of that.
CHRIS JACKSON: It's
still evolving.
It's still finding its way.
But it's really
beautiful to be reminded
that when you go
through these processes,
there is a certain amount of
transformation that happens
and discovery that
happens, and there's
something about suffering for
nine months with uncertainty,
and with the dire
aspect of everything.
Every time you go in, it's
the most important moment
that you've ever
found in your life,
found yourself in, except
you found yourself in it.
ASHLEY PARK: It's
like pregnancy.
Isn't pregnancy like--
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah.
Pregnancy.
Say, I love my baby, but the
last thing I want to say,
not to interject, but the
cool thing is actually,
I got the job in this building.
The audition was on
the fourth, I think,
fourth floor of this building.
ASHLEY PARK: Of this building?
ARI'EL STACHEL:
Yeah, fifth floor.
ASHLEY PARK: Oh, the
Atlantic Theater Company.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Fifth
floor, that's where it was.
Yeah.
ASHLEY PARK: That's where
you birthed your baby.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah.
ASHLEY PARK: The end
of the pregnancy.
ARI'EL STACHEL:
She's in the back.
It'll be good.
I'm just kidding.
CHRIS JACKSON: No, Ashley,
just to switch gears
just a little bit.
You were in the tour
of "Cinderella."
ASHLEY PARK: Yeah.
Yes.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Did I do that?
CHRIS JACKSON: And now
you're in "Mean Girls."
ASHLEY PARK: Yes.
CHRIS JACKSON:
Playing a mean girl?
ASHLEY PARK: No.
CHRIS JACKSON: No?
Are you a nice girl?
ASHLEY PARK: Yes.
Yes.
This is my fourth
show on Broadway,
and it's the first one I've
done originating a role.
CHRIS JACKSON: How about it?
What was that
experience like for you?
ASHLEY PARK: It was
great, but it also
did feel like my other--
I mean, my last two
shows were big revivals,
and this kind of felt like
a revival in some ways
just because "Mean
Girls" is so iconic,
and everybody loves
these characters so much.
And it was Tina Fey
again, so like it
was the best process
though because I just
think a show is such
a collaboration,
and when you have
an amazing team,
and a team that is
going to encourage--
I mean, I feel like
the Gretchen Wieners
that I have now is the
baby product of truly
my entire team.
And they are very,
very supportive
of trying to find what was
honest about the character
in me, and the comedy of that
character and how I speak
and how I interpret what that
character is going through.
And so, I mean, she's the best.
I love Gretchen.
I do.
People at the stage
door are always like,
oh, I love Gretchen.
And I was like, I do
too, which is fun.
CHRIS JACKSON: Do you do you
find that because of the cult
status, if you
will, of the film,
do you feel pressured to hit
certain marks because of it,
or do you just feel
absolutely free
that you've created, in
essence, a new version of what
you're working with?
ASHLEY PARK: Yeah.
I think there are
definitely some markers.
There are some epic
lines that come in.
But we have our little
spin on it for everything.
I mean, the basic things
are, first of all,
you have an aging role on
the marquis of like the three
plastics.
That's different.
We're singing and we're
dancing, which is completely
different from the movie.
And it's a totally
different medium.
And also our show
takes place in 2018,
and is a totally different
book, but it's still
Tina Fey's voice.
And it feels very relevant.
So yeah.
CHRIS JACKSON: All right.
I'm going to ask this
question for you guys.
Coolest person you've met
backstage after a show.
Go.
ARIANA DEBOSE:
Like in the show--
in this one.
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah.
The other one doesn't count.
The other one was
a little like--
that other one was just stupid.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Dumb, so dumb.
ASHLEY PARK: What are
you guys talking about?
CHRIS JACKSON: I should say,
so like the best post-show
encounter or
conversation, and that
can be not just with a
celebrity, but with a fan,
whatever.
What would you--
ARIANA DEBOSE: Two short ones.
Whoopi Goldberg because
she was friends with Donna,
and it was just a moment where
she looked at all three of us
and was like, Donna was
here in each one of you.
And that meant a lot, number
one, because Whoopi is Whoopi.
CHRIS JACKSON: As
mama would be, yeah.
Whoopi.
And
ARIANA DEBOSE: Then number
two, just because she
had a first-hand knowledge
of Donna's sensibility.
And that's what we've always
been after, is the sensibility,
not to impersonate , but
we wanted her essence.
So that felt really
good to know.
And then there was this woman.
I don't know how old she was.
I would say she was
probably in her 70s,
but she was in a wheelchair.
And she waited at the end
of the stage door line.
And it took a minute for
all of us to get down there.
But when I finally
got down there,
I was able to speak to her.
She literally just took my hand
and cried, and said, thank you.
And that was it.
Like she could speak, like she
was just confined to her chair,
but that moment, just a
pure human connection,
it was just so beautiful
to be reminded that that
is the reason why we do this.
The theater is good
communion, right?
It's like, it is
good communion when
it's in its finest truest form.
And for her that day,
that's what we provided.
And that felt really cool
to know that the disco
queen was able to do that.
So yeah.
CHRIS JACKSON: Now, we already
know you had steak with Denzel.
I'm just saying.
ASHLEY PARK: Does he
know who you are, though?
CHRIS JACKSON: Just
humble brag, just humble.
ARI'EL STACHEL:
He does, kind of.
He will.
For me, it's a
similar experience.
I remember we were, I think,
two weeks into previews,
and the stage doors when
fans are waiting outside.
And there's like a very
little opening for Tony
to get into his car.
I mean, it's pretty
high security.
But this young Palestinian
girl found her way through it,
ran through it into my arms,
with tears in her eyes,
and hugged me, crying.
And she assumed I spoke Arabic
because I speak it in the show.
I don't fluently, but
she just could not
believe that representation
of her people was on stage.
And that experience
has actually recurred.
Not everyone is
running past the gates,
but those conversations
are happening over and over
with kids who are
seeing this new pathway.
And sometimes, with
Chris Jackson in mind,
depending on the person, if I
see that they have something
and I believe that they
really want to do this,
I'll do the exact same
thing because of you,
and I'll bring them backstage
and say the same thing.
It's just a mezzanine.
ARIANA DEBOSE:
That's a good line.
ASHLEY PARK: Copyright.
ARI'EL STACHEL: But
no, I really do that.
And so it's those experiences
when you realize that there's
a social impact because as a
Broadway actor, Tony nominated,
I mean, I'm living my
life 24 hours a day.
You know what I mean?
I'm doing my laundry.
I'm getting fruit
at Whole Foods.
like I'm just living my life.
So when you realize that
there is that impact
and you actually see it,
those are the moments
that mean the most to me.
CHRIS JACKSON: And having
a steak with Denzel
is not a bad lunch.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Not
a bad thing either.
CHRIS JACKSON:
It's not a bad lu--
I wouldn't mind having
a steak dinner--
ASHLEY PARK: We get
a lot of fun people.
I mean, although, the coolest
part about like the SNL people
coming is--
a lot of the
celebrities who come
are really so proud of Tina too.
They're so proud of her
and her Broadway and stuff.
So there's actually like,
yeah, there's a celebrity here,
but they're also like,
thank you for being
part of our friends thing.
Like they're just so
excited to be there too,
which is like awesome.
And then for me personally,
having like Andre Bishop
and Bart Sher come and
be like, oh, my god,
we had the best time
with our daughters,
and we're so proud
of you for that.
And it feels like a different
part of the Broadway family
that is there, and
that it just reminds
me of like, it always
every time there's
like a little Asian
girl at the stage door,
and there's one in particular
who is very little,
and like couldn't even
look over the thing.
I almost like passed
her by, and she
was like, I never saw myself.
I know what I want to do.
And I was like, aw.
And I was like being little,
and being like, oh my god,
like watching Barney.
I just want to be one
of the Barney kids.
Yeah, is that why we're
singing and dancing?
CHRIS JACKSON: I just want
to be one of the Barney kids.
ASHLEY PARK: But what
was so crazy and cool
was like right next
to her was this
like older, I'm
going to say he was
a gay white boy, like teenager,
and he was like, girl,
I saw myself in Gretchen.
Like, thank you so much.
And I was like, yeah!
Let's all take a selfie.
CHRIS JACKSON: Just
lifting up the people.
ASHLEY PARK: No, those
genuine interactions.
It's like, oh, my gosh, it's not
about having fans or anything.
It's like, I genuinely
connected with these two
and like, thanks
Gretchen, thanks Tina.
Like that.
CHRIS JACKSON: That's awesome.
Open up the floor
to some questions.
Anybody have any questions for
these wonderful actors that
have come here,
and they're awake?
ARI'EL STACHEL: Oh, there we go.
CHRIS JACKSON: Feeling things.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question
about your inspirations
for pursuing a life
in the theater.
Is there a particular Broadway
show or a Broadway performer
that you looked up to, that
helped reinforce your decision
to pursue this career?
ARIANA DEBOSE: Oh, wow.
Who's got a good one?
I feel like I go
first all the time.
But I'm just going to do it
because I know what I'll say.
I want to be Madonna's backup
dancer when I was a kid.
That was my plan.
I was going to go to LA.
And funny, make plans.
That'll teach you otherwise.
So I had done "So You
Think You Can Dance,"
didn't exactly work
out how I'd planned,
and came to New York on a whim
to audition for some stuff,
and got a job.
And I met up with Charlotte
Dubois, Tony nominee and dance
legend.
Decided she would
have lunch with me.
I felt very special.
And she said, just
come to New York.
Come to New York and stay here.
So I did.
And as I got to know her, she
truly, within six months time,
changed my perspective
on everything.
Like I was like, why is anyone
going to take me seriously?
I'm a little brown girl from
North Carolina who kicks
real good and that could be it.
You know what I mean?
She was like, no, you
are here for a reason.
And she coached me within
an inch of my life,
helped me figure out
how to say a sentence
and get to the end of the line.
She was literally holding
my hand through this.
But if she had not
done that, I don't
think I would have stayed.
So I owe a lot to
her in that way.
And she's a constant
reminder to just stay open
and to keep saying yes because
I think that's probably
how I ended up where I am.
Stay open and say yes.
Thanks, Char.
Love you.
How about you, guy?
ARI'EL STACHEL: You go first.
ASHLEY PARK: I think that, well,
I mean, I grew up in Michigan,
and I had never been to--
Yeah!
And I'm realizing
now, like I really
think that cast albums
were a big thing for me.
Like I remember "Wicked" and
"Thoroughly Modern Millie,"
and like "Spring Awakening."
And I would just listen to
them and I would imagine.
I think that was my
real access to this.
I mean, my favorite
movie growing up
was "Sound of Music,"
like Julie Andrews,
Kelley O'Hara, Sutton Foster.
Like all of those ladies, I
remember listening to them.
I loved Adina and Kristen
on that album too,
and I watched "Wicked"
like in Chicago,
in Detroit, and all this
stuff, and long story short, I
had cancer in high school.
And the Make A Wish
Foundation, they grant a wish
and my wish was to go
watch a Broadway show
because I hadn't done that.
And I was like, I really
think that theater
is what I want to do.
They were really nice, the
Make a Wish Foundation.
They flew my entire
family out here.
I'd never been to New
York, and they gave me
a very bad preconceived
notion for how
New York was because we were
in this fancy hotel with a limo
everywhere.
And I was like, this
is New York, baby.
And we watched not one,
but four, Broadway shows.
The first show I ever
saw was "Lion King,"
and "Spring Awakening,"
which my dad had gone back
to work at that point.
Thank god I didn't
watch that with him.
And "Chorus Line,"
which my sister
fell asleep in, but like
Pulitzer Prize winning.
We love it.
Yeah, so that was like,
and then after that trip,
and like since I went to
high school in Ann Arbor,
Michigan-- that's where
the University of Michigan
is that I eventually went to--
and a lot of those students
would come, musical
theater students,
would come and direct
our high school shows.
And a lot of them,
one of them being
Etai, who's in
the show with you,
and like so I had
a lot of mentors
who were in that program and
who are still in the industry.
And I have them to thank too.
ARI'EL STACHEL: I need
to answer that one?
It's hard for me.
I mean, we keep talking about
it, but I think in the heights,
and watching these guys
was really impactful for me
because that was at a
time where I was just
sort of figuring
out if this is what
I wanted to pursue in college.
I think I was 16,
17 at the time.
So seeing them at
least speak sort
of the cultural language
of our generation
was really important to me.
It made me feel
like I had a way in.
And I remember just feeling
like when I got to college,
like I identified with this.
And I could do it in a way
that lots of the other kids
couldn't because I
was a person of color.
So it was sort of a
mixture of that show,
but the truth is that
it was really just,
I originally wanted to
play basketball as a kid,
and I just, like when
I was 15, I realized
I just wasn't good enough.
There was a classmate I had
who was 6'8" and dunking,
and I was like,
this is not for me.
ASHLEY PARK: So I'm
going to do theater.
ARI'EL STACHEL: So, I'm
Well, you know what?
I always wanted to like
succeed in like a big way.
And I always knew that as a kid.
And like the one thing that
I had was like, OK, not
basketball.
Then I wanted to dance, and
I also wasn't good at that.
But I switched to an arts
high school as a dance major,
and to answer, the
real person that
made me want to do it was,
there was this dance teacher who
was like the basketball
coach I never had and wanted.
He just loved art.
And I wanted to do it so bad.
I went to an arts
high school and we
would dance for like
five hours at the school,
and I was so obsessed
with it that I
would go eat pasta at my house,
and then for three hours,
go to his night classes.
And I remember the way he
talked about just the journey
of an artist, and he would be
like, man, the amount of people
who want to be good
dancers is like this, man.
It sounds like hoooooo.
And he was talking about just
not wanting to be mediocre,
just this never ending pursuit
of excellence and of the work.
And that's just excited me,
and so I'm still very much sort
of in pursuit of that thing.
But yeah.
ARIANA DEBOSE: That's
a good pursuit to have.
ASHLEY PARK: You
know what I mean?
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah.
ASHLEY PARK: Being open.
ARIANA DEBOSE:
Everybody say yes.
Let's not be mediocre.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
ARI'EL STACHEL: But you
see also how much people
love it, and devote their lives
to it and feel alive by it.
ASHLEY PARK: What kind of dance?
CHRIS JACKSON: Athletic.
Athletic.
ARI'EL STACHEL: For
a year and a half,
I was taking ballet
and modern then.
ARIANA DEBOSE: It's freeing.
It's freeing.
You know what I mean?
ARI'EL STACHEL:
Yeah, it's freeing.
Y'all don't want to
see me do it now, but--
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah,
that's not necessary.
We've got another question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hey,
thanks for coming.
Hey.
How you doing?
CHRIS JACKSON: Hey.
AUDIENCE: A technology company.
I was wondering if you
guys could talk about,
in your experience over the
years, how you have seen
technology change the business,
how it's affected things,
and also-- it's kind of
a two-part question--
technology and social
media, and if that change,
in your opinion, is good or not?
ARIANA DEBOSE: Oh, wow.
I have so many thoughts.
ASHLEY PARK: Well, I mean,
technology in terms of like set
piece, just like very
basic, is like I mean,
like our show is completely
like all screens,
and it's a very warm
feeling, and we're grounded
and everything, but like
that technology did not
exist 10 years ago.
The capability of
changing sets that fast--
ARIANA DEBOSE:
Definitely involved.
ASHLEY PARK: --did not exist.
Everything is much faster paced.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Mm-hmm.
Definitely.
I mean, and I was
going to say, I mean,
with social media
and cell phones--
ASHLEY PARK: Half of our
campaign is all social media.
ARIANA DEBOSE: It's
all social media.
It's moved the industry,
I think, forward
in a lot of great ways.
We're much more accessible to
lots of different demographics
than we ever were before,
which is very exciting.
I also think, though, everybody
wants to put their Broadway
show on InstaStory.
Everybody sitting in
front of the headlights
likes to tell people
where they are,
and that they are
enjoying the show,
and da da da da, which is
super awesome and very, very
exciting.
It's also distracting.
So I think with the
excitement that technology
has allowed us to garner
for what it is that we do,
the caveat to that
is remembering that--
ASHLEY PARK: Live theater
is a sacred space.
ARIANA DEBOSE: It
is sacred space.
And this is also our job.
So if you wouldn't want Sally
Sue coming up in here, putting
a phone up in your
grill, while you're
doing whatever it is
that you take pride in,
that you love doing
day to day, perhaps
you might not do
that at the theater.
CHRIS JACKSON: Patti Lu
Pone, ladies and gentlemen.
ARIANA DEBOSE: She's a balto!
CHRIS JACKSON: Any
time someone asks me
that question, I
always say, imagine
what would have happened if cell
phones and texting and Twitter
were around when "Rent" hit.
Right?
And then look at
how "Hamilton" hit.
You see the two--
you know what I mean?
You go to the Nederlander
Theater in '96,
and there are 500
people waiting in line,
sleeping outside all
night just for 20 seats.
That was before you could
do online lotteries.
ARI'EL STACHEL:
Or hand for hand.
CHRIS JACKSON: Or hand,
all of those things.
ARI'EL STACHEL: All that stuff.
CHRIS JACKSON: Those things
weren't available 20 years ago.
10 years ago, they
weren't really available.
I remember sitting
backstage with Lin
when Facebook was the thing
we were making videos for,
in the Heights, and it was
still like the craziest thing
you could imagine.
Like let's do a
video on your phone.
We got 30 seconds.
Let's go.
And he would make it,
and now we look back
on all of those videos,
but before that, he
had an Easy Share camera that
he had to like record, and then
upload onto his laptop,
and then he would post it.
And now, it's just like, that
was really labor intensive.
Why would anybody do that?
Except it was another way of
communicating with the world.
And so outside of videoing, or--
ASHLEY PARK: The show.
CHRIS JACKSON: --the show, have
you found, in a personal way--
what have you found
your interactions
like with the public on
Twitter, or on Facebook,
or have you pursued it?
Have you avoided it?
What's been your
experience with that?
ASHLEY PARK: I mean, I
don't have a Facebook,
and I'm not very
active on Twitter,
but I love Instagram because
my mom was a scrapbooker.
So I grew up with her
like scrapbooking,
and so like I consider it
like my modern day scrapbook.
Like I love it.
CHRIS JACKSON: Without the
little quirky scissors?
ASHLEY PARK: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, you have like all the
little gifts and stuff now.
So like I love that, and I
love interacting in that way.
I love sharing.
And also because like,
especially in like a whirlwind
like this past month.
I'm going to wake
up in like a month
and not remember any of it.
ARIANA DEBOSE: That's
your scrapbook.
ASHLEY PARK: And so
I'm going to be like,
oh, look at that was a fun day.
like that's really
fun, to remember that.
ARI'EL STACHEL: That's
actually stressful.
I find it stressful to have to--
I find myself like in an event,
and then like five minutes
is devoted to figuring
out which angle to take
the picture of the cookie.
ASHLEY PARK: You got
to be natural with it.
Like it'll come to you, man.
CHRIS JACKSON: Just
take a shot and go.
ARI'EL STACHEL:
Just take a shot.
ARIANA DEBOSE:
I'm half and half.
I'm like you.
I love Instagram.
And I think a picture
says a thousand words.
So I do focus on that capture,
less of the video content.
But I love--
Chris Jackson!
CHRIS JACKSON: I love you.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Always
laughing at me.
But I love being able to connect
with fans through Instagram.
I like being able to
receive direct messages.
It's a great way for them
to share their stories,
whereas like I use my social
media platform, share mine.
What I will say is, I do find
myself a little on edge when
it comes to Twitter,
just because I
think it allows people to be
really free with their words.
Like people will just
about write anything.
And they will say
anything about you,
to you, which I
think is very brave,
but then it also gives me pause.
It was like, I don't feel
the need to defend myself.
I'm not in a line of work
that is really defensive,
I don't believe.
But I do give myself
pause because some
of the things that
I do receive may not
be positive all the time.
CHRIS JACKSON: So you
have to filter it.
ARIANA DEBOSE: You do.
CHRIS JACKSON: Will I open?
Yeah.
ASHLEY PARK: I will say,
it's distracting too,
with the art sometimes
in terms of ever placing
any value on that kind
of thing where like, oh,
like I have this many
followers, or this many likes.
Like anytime it gets
into that territory
of ever putting self worth
or self value in something
like that, that's something
our show is kind of about.
That's dangerous territory.
But in terms of technology too,
I will say that logistics wise,
it makes things easier,
such as, I forget that
10 years ago, or 20 years ago,
simple things like the stage
manager sending out a schedule
for the day, or being like,
OK, this person is out tonight.
We have to have an
emergency put in at 7:00 PM.
Like they would have to
either individually call
people or whatever, like
have a paper up rather
than just e-mailing everybody.
So like in those ways, it
makes the logistics of Broadway
a lot easier and
more accessible.
ARIANA DEBOSE: And
more efficient.
ASHLEY PARK: And more efficient.
ARIANA DEBOSE: It's
way more efficient.
CHRIS JACKSON: You
have a question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just want to make a comment.
I'm really excited to go
see "Mean Girls" tomorrow
with the Alumni Association.
ASHLEY PARK: Oh, my
god, is that tomorrow?
OK.
I mean, yeah, no.
AUDIENCE: But besides that's,
the industry that you're in
is incredibly competitive.
And now you are
all Tony nominees.
And so what has it been
throughout your career,
like after school and after
training and everything, what
kept you going and what
kept you persevering
to get to this point?
ASHLEY PARK: Well,
I think something
that I learned in school,
like my favorite motto is
that you can't move forward if
you're looking side to side.
And I think that
the notion of, like
you have to realize very quickly
that everyone's path is so
vastly different and so unique.
And so as soon as
you're just focused
on finding what feels
honest and true to yourself,
like no matter what you
do, then you never--
I don't know.
Like of course, our industry,
it's all rejection too,
but there's a lot of joy and as
soon as we lift each other up
and we support
each other, and we
support each other's
successes, and it never feels
like a failure to anybody.
CHRIS JACKSON: Community.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah, totally.
That is a great part about
being a part of the Broadway
industry, this
particular facet of it,
is we do function very
much like a community.
And so when one
of us is down, we
do really rally
around each other.
So I do a lot of yoga.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yoga.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Center yourself.
Keep your feet on the
ground as much as you can,
very much what you
were talking about.
Like find your smaller community
within a larger community.
CHRIS JACKSON: I've always
felt too, if you do more,
you do one show
that runs, you meet
everybody's friend,
everyone's significant other,
and their parents.
And then from the
time that you do
that one show to the
next show that comes up,
there's usually like
four or five readings.
So you end up just sort of--
ASHLEY PARK: It's
truly a network.
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah, it really
becomes that very quickly.
ARI'EL STACHEL: But I think the
thing that sort of sustains me
through the rejection, which
I've had, I'm sure all of us
have had plenty of,
is that I really think
it's really an important thing.
Like I come from a family that
fights for social justice.
My mom does work in
Africa in clinics,
making sure that
women can give birth
in a more healthy way
and more safe way.
And so as long as I'm
remembering from a larger
global perspective that
I'm after that larger
social mission, it dilutes
the rejection a little bit.
And speaking of, like we're
doing something important,
but like the other
day, I think it
was like five days after
my Tony nomination,
and I was biking
through Chinatown.
And there was a guy with
like a stick on his back
with like 500 bottles in
one bag and 500 bottles
in the other bag.
He doesn't care about
the Tony awards.
You know what I mean?
So I think that that
keeps it in perspective.
But when you do it,
hopefully it helps people.
And I think both of these women
were saying, and Chris saying,
like when you help people, when
you're creating more equity,
and when you're inspiring
people, that's what it's for.
And again, so I
think that dilutes
the sting of a
rejection because you
have to have a larger
perspective about what
we're doing.
ASHLEY PARK: And also, we
have to really love it.
Like you have to
really, really love it.
Whenever someone
asks that question,
I'm like, as long as you like--
I think in our blood and
sweat, like in our bones,
we really love doing theater.
And you have to love it to
do it eight times a week.
It's really, really hard on
our bodies, on our minds,
on our souls.
But as long as we're
surrounded by good people,
and we're really enjoying
it-- like as soon as I don't
enjoy it anymore, like, bye.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah.
No, and I think one of the
greatest pieces of advice I
ever got was from Judith Light.
And this was early on.
I think I was still doing
"Bring It On," and she said,
you have to live
a life of service.
Like theater arts is a
service business, in a way.
So if you are
bringing your talents
to the table in a way that can
be of service to someone else,
and you lead in that
direction, then you
will always be on your path.
It's like, heart
forward in that way.
And that's really helped
me because I pride myself
on being a creator.
I love to create.
Sometimes there's
not a space for that.
So then you have to be willing
to go create your own space,
but that's where we are.
CHRIS JACKSON: That's
what artists do.
ARIANA DEBOSE: That's
So it's cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you all
for being here today.
You guys are all so inspiring,
and I definitely found myself
tearing up a few times today.
So but I have a
lighter question.
What is your favorite
Schmackary's cookie flavor?
ASHLEY PARK: Oh, my gosh.
Why?
Are you going to send them?
What?
No sin salad.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Are these the
ones with the frosting on top?
ASHLEY PARK: Funfetti.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Funfetti.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Is
that what it is?
ASHLEY PARK: With
the rainbow frosting.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Anything
with frosting is--
They all have frosting.
ASHLEY PARK: Yeah.
I mean, the Funfetti
is like crack.
Are we allowed to say crack?
I mean, yeah.
It is.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Their gluten-free
cookie's bangin' too.
ASHLEY PARK: Yeah, the corn one?
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah,
it's really great.
ASHLEY PARK: The corn one,
and the macho one too.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Yeah, they
transcribe it as crack.
I was wondering if they
were going to censor it.
ASHLEY PARK: Oh, they're
writing what we said.
CHRIS JACKSON: That's forever.
ASHLEY PARK: Oh, it is forever.
The macho one too,
she's describing it.
Well, OK, it is.
Oh, no, I'm distracted.
CHRIS JACKSON: You can only
eat Schmackary's-- if you're an
actor, you can only eat
Schmackary's when you're doing
eight shows a week.
ARIANA DEBOSE: That's so true.
CHRIS JACKSON: Because
otherwise, it makes you--
ASHLEY PARK: In "Mean Girls," we
get like the packages of them,
and so we love one.
Like our doorman will be
like, so-and-so, there's
a Schmackary's delivery,
and we all run downstairs.
CHRIS JACKSON: You
get to the green room
and there's only a card left.
All the cookies are gone.
AUDIENCE: I actually brought
some Schmackary's for you all.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Oh,
wait, what kind?
CHRIS JACKSON: Favorite
guest of the day.
ASHLEY PARK: Yay, thank you.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah, I want
to eat the Funfetti kind.
ASHLEY PARK: Oh, my god.
Open 'em
CHRIS JACKSON: Eat 'em up, guys.
Eat 'em up.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ARIANA DEBOSE: That
was so sweet of you.
CHRIS JACKSON: Do you
have Schmackary's too?
OK, enjoy your seat.
I'm sorry.
They're going to
look through those.
Ask the question.
I'll make sure they get it.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to say to
you first, I'm really excited,
ARI'EL STACHEL: Thank
you, love, thank you.
ARI'EL STACHEL: God bless you.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: But
also, I was looking
through all your
Instagram stories earlier
and you guys are very busy.
Like you did a
two-mile run before you
came, which is phenomenal.
CHRIS JACKSON: Which one?
AUDIENCE: You do?
CHRIS JACKSON: It's
six mile, yeah.
ASHLEY PARK: Shut up
and eat your cookie.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Eat your cookie.
AUDIENCE: My question is,
how do you guys manage time
doing like eight shows
a week, and then trying
to have like a social life?
ASHLEY PARK: Well, I
did an eight-mile run,
and I decided I didn't need
to put it on social media.
So you should all know that.
ARI'EL STACHEL: I think
it ebbs and flows.
I think there are times
when it really accelerates,
and social life
takes a dip and you
got to do something
early in the morning.
And then other
times, it doesn't.
You know what I mean.
Like when we're
leading up to opening,
there's just so much stuff,
you can't see anyone.
So I think that's
built into what we do,
that there's times
where it ebbs and flows.
ASHLEY PARK: I like to
trick my body into thinking,
and this is a problem
of mine, like not
being able to say no
to stuff, but like,
I like to trick my mind
into thinking like,
OK, if I'm planning
all this stuff,
I'm saying yes to Brian Behrs.
I'm saying yes to I'm going to
throw myself a birthday party
tomorrow, even though it's
Tony's week, because whatever.
If I see everybody
that I want to see,
then my body's
like, OK, you're not
going to shut down just yet.
Like you can't be sick because
you're doing all this stuff.
That's not a healthy way
sometimes to go about it.
But it makes it more fun.
I don't know.
ARIANA DEBOSE: No, totally.
I mean, I sort of live like
a hermit, a little bit.
Like the stamina that I
have to maintain is a lot,
but I don't necessarily have
the energy to do the six miles.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Because
you dance in your show.
ARIANA DEBOSE: I do,
so my show kind of
keeps me going in a way.
I will say, that's been a
really nice through line
about all the extra that comes
with this amazing opportunity.
I can rely on my show.
ASHLEY PARK: Show,
it's a safe place.
ARIANA DEBOSE: I always
have my show to go back to.
And that's really nice.
But I don't see anyone.
I'm at home with my two cats
pretty much all the time.
It's great.
ASHLEY PARK: That's great.
I'm a lot more
social on this show
than I have been with like, like
I permitted for other shows.
So because "Mean Girls" is
also like a party on stage
every night.
CHRIS JACKSON:
Have you also found
that the more physically
demanding the show
is, that is what ends up
regulating your outside life?
ASHLEY PARK: Absolutely, yes.
CHRIS JACKSON: Like if you've
got to go home and sleep.
I never went out when
we did "Hamilton."
I always went home
because I had to do the--
ASHLEY PARK: Is that
the show you did?
CHRIS JACKSON: Yeah.
But because I had to get up with
my kids every morning at 7:30
when everybody else was
sleeping until noon.
So you know what I mean?
You end up making choices
and it dictates how
you navigate through the world.
ASHLEY PARK: I don't know
how you parents do it too.
CHRIS JACKSON: I
don't know either.
ARIANA DEBOSE: That's a thing.
CHRIS JACKSON: Don't have kids.
ASHLEY PARK: I think that's
what we're going for right now
because we know that when
have families one day,
maybe it'd be harder.
ARIANA DEBOSE: Oh, yeah.
One day, there will come
a moment where I'm like,
I'm going to take
a break because I
need to go have what I consider
to be a real life for a minute.
ASHLEY PARK: Is no one
else eating a cookie?
ARI'EL STACHEL: I'm having some.
ARIANA DEBOSE: So
you only live once,
and you're only a
first-time nominee once.
So we take advantage
of everything.
I can't believe--
CHRIS JACKSON: Listen.
10 second answers, OK,
because I got to read a blurb.
What's Monday morning going
to be like for you guys?
ASHLEY PARK: What's Monday?
ARIANA DEBOSE: I'm sleeping in.
CHRIS JACKSON: OK,
you're going to sleep in?
ARIANA DEBOSE: Yeah.
ARI'EL STACHEL: I will
still be partying.
Don't I have until seven?
Isn't that the thing?
CHRIS JACKSON: Are you dark on--
ARI'EL STACHEL: We're
dark on Mondays.
CHRIS JACKSON: Oh,
then you're good.
ASHLEY PARK: Me too.
I don't know.
ARI'EL STACHEL: You will be.
ASHLEY PARK: I mean, I
will look at my calendar.
I don't know.
ARIANA DEBOSE: I
do know I'm hosting
a gala for Live Out Loud, which
is an LGBT youth organization.
I'm very excited about that.
It is the night
after the Tonys, so--
ARI'EL STACHEL: Sleep
in and then you'll--
ARIANA DEBOSE: Sleep
in and pray for me.
Send me your best thoughts,
and maybe more Schmacks.
Thanks.
CHRIS JACKSON: Well,
first of all, can we just
thank this amazing panel?
And here's what you need to
know about Sunday, if you
don't already know.
The 72nd annual Tony awards.
The previous Tony
award nominees,
Sarah Bareilles and Josh Groban
will host the awards show,
live from the historic
Radio City Music
Hall in New York City,
Sunday, June 10, 2018,
from 8:00 to 11:00 eastern
time delayed and Pacific time
on CBS.
The Tony awards were first held
in 1947 at the Waldorf Astoria
grand ballroom.
There you go, right?
And the ceremony is presented
by Tony Award Productions which
is a joint venture of
the Broadway League
and the American theater
wing which founded the Tonys.
And on behalf of these
amazing performers and myself,
thank you so much for coming
and spending time with us today.
And good luck on Sunday.
[APPLAUSE]
ARIANA DEBOSE: Thank you.
ARI'EL STACHEL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]